our teams from three Lifeboat stations
in Kent were involved in that
multi-agency operation the rescue in the
channel but of course involved that
fishing vessel that just happened to be
nearby as that inflatable started taking
on water a great panic and as you say
Kent County Council confirming the
really harrowing details of
unaccompanied
youngsters on that vessel that they have
now taken into their care and also
confirming that one of the four who died
was a teenager the process of
identifying those who lost their lives
is still ongoing and of course that
might be quite a difficult process and
might involve contacting families in
different parts of the world so a very
harrowing situation involving young
people we don't know the precise ages of
those who lost their lives or indeed
whether they could be further people who
were lost at sea the search operation
was continuing overnight with drones
being used in the middle of the channel
to try and scour the area very difficult
challenging conditions of course for
those who are out on vessels given the
very very cold temperatures and the rnli
here in Dungeness really paying tribute
to the bravery and compassion of those
on those UK fishing vessels who were
involved and also their Crews who took
part in the rescue and recovery of
people from the water and also the
search process that followed on after
those people who had survived had got
back to shore